なぜ語る？なぜ聞くということ
今まで言ったのは何でしたかね？コミュニケーションというのはあり得ないんだ
よく喋ってるつもりでしょ
何も理解していないよ
お互い様 なのに我々は喋る
なのに聞く 成り立たないコミュニケーションを重視する理由は何でしょうか
読みだけにしましょう
一人では生きていられない
生きられない 存続するために周りの情報を理解する必要があります
知識を得るためではありません
皆様方 本を読んだり 勉強したり
人と喋ったりするのは勘違いしないでください
頭良くなるためでも 知識得るためでも
理性人になるためではないんです
そんなこと知らなかったらちょっと危ないんですよ
生きていられなくなります
猫にハムスターは獲物として理解できるが
可愛いと理解できません
でしょ？皆様が飼っているハムスターがね
可愛いことたまらんでしょう
猫が見ると尾を振って狙うんです
猫にとっては獲物なんです
可愛いと理解できないんです
これ フィルターなんです
まずフィルターの例なんですけど
だから猫にとっては あの
ハムスターというのは人間飼ってる動物の中の一部であると
もうハムスターはまあそれなりにまあ私と似ているものを食ってるんだと
まあ性格は違いますよと
あれが俺と理解する？全然できません
猫にとっては食えばいい
それで生き延びるんです
だから我々本読んだり勉強したりするのも同じく
あの存続のためなんです
猫と変わってないんです
人間にカエルはごちそうとして理解できないが
ヘビには餌なんです 皆様方はカエル見たらペロペロペロと舐めますよ
あ ごちそうおいしそうと
無理でしょう しかし ヘビは
そういうことで 我々知っている情報っていうのは変ですよ
我々にはヘビにカエルはどのように見えるかを知る余地はないんです
ヘビにも人間がカエル対してどんな気持ちかとわからない
我々にとっては ヘビは嫌いな動物でもどうにもならんですね
だからってヘビは嫌いな気持ち悪い動物でしょうかね
だから私たちは自分の存続のため
例えば猿もいますよ 猿もヘビが見るだけでいっばい怖がるんです
同じ猿の仲間である人間も
あのヘビを見ただけですごく怖くなるんです
なぜでしょうかね 怖いんです
噛まれたら死ぬんです
これがあるんですよ 噛まれたこともないのに
毒蛇がいると教えなくても怖いんです
例えば猿なんかはヘビに毒があること知らないでしょうから
知らないんだけど 見ただけで怖くなる
知られる範囲と理解できる範囲があるんです
それで覚えておいてください
我々人間にしても猫にしても知られる範囲があります
それから理解できるレベル
容量というものがあります
だから人間に理解できる範囲がありますけど
一人一人人間にはどれぐらいの量が持てるかという器の問題もあります
自分の都合で作った情報をそのまま完全に相手に理解されたいんでしょ
これ 発信者の希望なんです
皆さんはそう思ってるでしょ？私言うことよく理解しなさいとかね
あんた なんで私の気持ちを理解してくれないのかとかね
これ不可能だと思ってないんで
特に女性はね 男の人も鬼の休憩中のことといじめるんです
私の気持ちを理解しなさい
だから男たち聞いてください
あなたの気持ち何ですか？どうにもわからない
一番自分の気持ちわかってないのは女性なんです
私 調べたんだからね 冗談どうしようもない
男に聞けば 今私はこんな気分
こんな気分 こんな気分
堂々と言うんです だから男同士では
もう私の気持ちなんでわからないの？という言葉は一回も起こりませんでしょ
一回も起こりません それで女性の間
女性と男性の間で 毎回それが起こるんです
だからわかりたいんだけど
女性ってどんな気持ちでいるんですかね？知ってるんですかね
それはもうちょっと冗談で意味がないんだけど
まあそこら辺だからね
ちょっと余計な話をしますけど
えーと 発言者が私の 言いたいことをそのまま理解しなさいという態度ですね
しかし 自分の都合のところだけ聞きた理解した
聞く人が相手が言っていることだけ全部知りたくはないんです
自分の都合によるものだけ聞きたいんです
これ 子供と話すとよくわかるでしょ
子供はよく耳を傾いてくれますけど
都合が悪くなってくると見事に話をすらってるんですね
別な話になってる 子供の
それは大人も同じく よく社会の決まり
決まりもありますから
なるほど よくそうですかね
やっぱりですねとか言うんだけど
聞いてないです ただ 自分の都合のいいこと言ったらもうすぐわかるんですね
だからこれはもうコミュニケーション術とは単純にこの 2つの気持ちのつなぎです
コミュニケーションというのは
私が全部理解させてやるぞと頑張るんです
相手がもう理解しませんよ
都合の良いところだったら
それだけ理解する だから私が強引に相手のフィルターを破ろうとする
相手が強引にフィルターを付けようとする
その綱引きなんです だからどこかで止まるでしょ
だから力関係というわけで
コミュニケーションというのは強い者の勝ちなんです
だから真実は必ず勝つという言葉があるでしょ
あれは英語ですか？日本語ですかね
日本語的じゃないんですね
真実は必ず勝つっていうのはね
あんまり日本大和心っぽいでないんでしょ
だからあれは英語から借りたでしょうね
トゥルースオールウェイズという
あれはあまり英語的じゃないんです
あれはインドの言葉なんです
サッチャメーワジャヤテという
まあインドの一般的な言葉なんです
サッチャメーワジャヤテ
勝つのは真理のみである
それは幻想的で希望的観想であって
実際は 強者の勝ちなんです
コミュニケーションの場合も
自分言いたいことを相手が理解してくれるとならば
発言者が強者であることは確かなんです
私を理解しなさい とはコミュニケーションの啓示です
だからコミュニケーションについての学問体系がありますからね
マスコミというね マスコミだけを教える大学まであるでしょう
結局はこのどんな世界でも啓示がありまして
神の言葉がありまして
これは私を理解しなさいなんです
馬鹿馬鹿らしいんです
あなたは何者か本人も知らないのにね
それからちょこっとそういうっぽい世界でマスコミ術に入ってみます
えーと 自分の都合で聞きたくなっていることを利用する
だから私が自分の都合で聞きたいものがあるんですよ
マスコミはそれを利用するんです
あの放送局は視聴率を気にするでしょ
放送局の場合は視聴率がとても大事な
もう命なんですね 魂よりも価値があるんですよ
くだらない数字は しかし
民間放送は NHK に簡単に負けますね
一度でも NHK に勝って視聴率を取ったことはないんです
なんでしょうかね 民放はスポンサーが言いたいことをに集中します
だから あれへとこれへと工夫して
スポンサーが言いたいことを強調します
それから あの では答えは？となんか派手になんかクイズ番組のようになって
はい では答えはと言った途端
はい コマーシャルの後
最低最悪でしょ あの高い子はなく
テレビはもう 1,000 3,000円ぐらいだったら
私はもう 1億台ぐらいテレビを買ってると思います
だから NHK ではそれはないんですよ
だから  NHK は国民が知りたいことを提供するんですよ
別に NHK が素晴らしい情報を与えているわけじゃないんです
NHK さんが日本国民が何を知りたいかと
おばあちゃんが来て 舞台で民謡を歌ったりして
これはもう喉が枯れていて
もう音調 なんて言いますか
音程が間違うわ もう無茶苦茶ですけど
やっぱり日本人にとってはもうすごい気分がいいんです
そこで喉自慢の場合も
合格になるのは歌唱力じゃないんです
僕 じっと何回も聞いていたんです
この合格基準は何なのか
歌唱力じゃない だから人気は死なないんです
あの番組は 皆さんは生まれる前に始めたでしょ
まだやってます まだ現役
要は 一般の普通の方々が
聞きたい情報を与えているんです
それがその発想で  NHK のマスターは日本国民だから
日本国民がスポンサーでしょ
だからもう民放は負けますよ
スポンサーの数を見ると
この三菱とかなんだらかんだら小っちゃな会社がね
提供したって 日本国民には勝てっこないでしょ
だからそういうことでね
まあ頑張ってますけどね
僕は人は他人が言いたいことに警戒する
なぜでしょうかね 人が他人が言いたいことには警戒するのが
私が知りたいことには警戒しません
だからマスコミがこの警戒の壁をなんのことなく掘っているんです
自分で言いたいことを言ってるんじゃなくて
人が知りたいことを言っています
例えば あの 試してガッテンという番組があるでしょ
もうタイトル見たってもダサくて見たくはないんだけど
しかし みんな見てるんです
視聴率もあるんです なぜですかね
知りたいことを言ってるんです
一回見たらもう次も見るぞっていうことになるんです
はい